hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
going to be my Legend of Korra finale
video lots of thoughts about the ending
and just the series in general so let's
do the thing I know we all really want
to talk about is the ending I do feel
like Mike and Bryan just absolutely
dropped the mic and just backed away if
you were to press them at a future
comic-con I think that they would stay
pretty ambiguous about the ending it's a
really common thing for writers
especially in television now when
there's an ending that's really
polarizing to just kind of leave it to
the fans to decide one way or the other
how things went down so just remember
that when you're arguing canon with
other people on tumblr because this is
the finale I'm giving away two copies of
the book three DVD all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video so careful for
spoilers from the finale if you haven't
seen the episode yet starting with top
ten moments number ten pema at the train
station one of my favorite quotes from
the episode I raised meelo I can handle
anything although it looks like Rohan at
the end of the episode is going to be
way crazier than meelo although he seems
a little more benign the song that she
was singing later was called hungry
little lemurs there's so many songs in
Avatar at some point I'll try to do a
video for my favorite avatar songs
especially from the original series I'm
surprised that they haven't released an
album usually at Comic Cons sometimes
they'll sing I'm like they saying secret
tunnel at Comic Con 2014 it was pretty
fun number nine Prince Wu with the
badgermoles
I loved that they gave him the Toph
moment it wouldn't be avatar without
badgermoles in the song that he's saying
was actually a nice spin on secret
tunnel I'm surprised at how smart we got
in these last couple of episodes and it
was nice to give him that big win
although technically it was a badger
mole win never let the truth get in the
way of a good story as Varrick says for
those that didn't remember from the
original avatar series it's the rhythm
of the song that the badger-moles are
responding to that's how they know to
take out the guards
number eight meelo has a plan to take
out the giant mech but really disable it
with the Airbender paintball guns isn't
it crazy that there was like a
windshield wiper system installed in the
giant mech that actually surprised me
more than the paintballs
I guess kuvira was just expecting to run
into a lot of inclement weather and I
just love meelo smashing his face on the
glass too that would be like a really
good dashboard or really good like phone
lock screen I've said it before but I
feel like he is the reincarnation of
Aang even though technically Korra is
she's the avatar meelo inherited a sense
of humor although I don't think the Aang
was quite as good of an artist number
seven team Korra versus the giant mech
round one they weren't able to take it
down but there was actually a really
awesome team effort with the airbenders
Korra and Bolin on the ground lava
bending the thing that's really crazy is
how good a metalbender kuvira is but
they kind of explained it later
like why she's able to bend the giant
mech and everyone else isn't outside
it's coated with platinum so that they
can't bend it from the outside but they
can bend it from the inside
that's why when suyun and lin got inside
later they were able to rip the out
of it in terms of raw bility though
kuvira is one of the best metal benders
in the world next to top that is top
still the best there were a number of
attacks against the mech and I do feel
like they did a good job of escalating
things so this actually came pretty
early in the first episode so it was a
big deal but the later fights did get
much more epic number 6 I'm afraid there
are no more things to do sir
Julian Varrick round one so many things
happen in this scene first off he did
the giant EMP like I thought he would of
course it didn't work just because the
power source inside the giant mech was
self-contained not only was the power
source isolated it was spirit vine
energy so it was a little bit different
from a traditional electric circuit the
way he tries to explain his backstory is
just so much fun I had an ostrich horse
named mrs. beaks and just that line
before the circus people came and took
me away doesn't it make you feel like he
was part of soohyun's circus troupe I
don't think that he was but just the
minute he said circus troupe all I could
think about was soohyun's picture from
her circus days farik is like a Homer
Simpson type character where they can
whip crack between personality traits
like they go from really smart to really
dumb back to really smart in the span of
like two minutes I don't know if anyone
was counting but I just thought it was
hilarious like the sheer number of times
they let different characters in the
episode use that phrase do the thing
number 5 Asami's father wants to turn
the hummingbird mix into mosquitoes and
then gives his life as predicted he did
help out I like the way they sent him
off they did give him that final
mountain with Asami like she said at the
end of the episode I'm glad that I
finally forgave him before it was too
late
built for words titled balance but I
think you could also subtitle it
forgiveness like a big part of balance
is forgiving people you could take that
as meta commentary from Mike and Brian
like please forgive us
there's not going to be another avatar
series the animation when they were
flying around the MEC was actually
really cool too it was like this very
King Kong moment with the mech trying to
swat them like actual flies number four
team Korra inside the mech so this is
really like a Death Star moment where
they all get inside start ripping it up
there are really three different plot
lines you have core versus kuvira up at
the top with the liquid metal fight then
you have bolin and ma KO in the engine
room trying to destroy the spirit finds
and then you have linen suyun trying to
take out the weapon first I just want to
appreciate all the cross sections just
like the internal mechanics they just
look so awesome you can definitely tell
they went all out with the animation on
this episode just for contrast they
could have totally taken the easy route
and never shown the inside of the mech
it would have been so much easier for
them to animate and so much cheaper so
actually going inside the Death Star way
above and beyond the call of duty never
mind how badass all the fights were so
let's start with the Korra fight up at
the top I love that the balls inside
those maneuvering mechanisms like the
things that cuvee were used to maneuver
the mech were liquid metal think of
those is like the gears like the way
that she shifts the mech around although
it does kind of seem like she's bending
from the inside of the mech like she's
bending the internal structure itself
it's also a nice reference to the poison
from the end of book three and you can
kind of tell the core is on our game
like the minute she jumps up there cuvee
ro throws it at her she bends it right
back at her at no point does the metal
cover her face like none of it gets on
her skin so she is definitely a much
better metal bender at this point I know
it's not always evident because she
hasn't spent a whole lot of time
fighting in book 4 like before wasn't so
much about fighting but Cora did have a
lot of epic bending when she wasn't in
the Avatar state moving down a little
bit Bolin and maka maka totally had his
hero moment I did kind of think he was
going to die and was going to end up in
the spirit world and they were gonna see
him in like a post-credits scene like
they would see him at the end of the
episode with Iroh trying to have tea but
to be fair you really only make it into
the spirit world as a spirit if your
spiritual alignment is highly tuned Iroh
was one of the most spiritual people
from the original avatar series so
that's that's why his spirit survives in
the spirit world
you don't just automatically go there so
to be fair if malko had died he actually
would not have ended up there he would
have just died so that would've been a
huge bummer so I am glad that bolin
saved him whenever he had that nod2 I
did think that Bolin was going to like
smack him in the face
and then escape with him and Bolin was
gonna do something I know one of the big
complaints in book three was why he
didn't light any bed minghua sooner but
he did get her in the end I was
definitely surprised at the explosion in
the giant mech like it was more of a
cross-section than it was like a nuclear
blast I expected it to be this big
spherical explosion like whenever the
spirit portal was created like a giant
blade was expanding from the inside and
how cool was Bolin - lava saw that was
the nice callback to cos and lava saw so
then moving to the side a little bit you
have suyun and beifong totally awesome
sister team-up you really do notice
there are heroes of all ages in the
avatar universe like you have Biddle
aged women you have children you have
really young children like meelo I think
that's one thing that they tried to add
from the original avatar series most of
the action focused on the young team
avatar but the core universe is a little
more diverse in terms of Ages
represented the only thing that
surprised me was how easily kuvira was
able to take them out I get that she's a
better bender than them
but it seems like she's just able to
swat them like flies when she bends them
to the metal arm and then rips it off
there aren't always little things like
that that bugged me when they don't
quantify people's strength I think a lot
of it just has to do with kuvira
catching them off guard if you ever
wonder why cougar is always able to beat
the crap out of people it's usually
because she catches them by surprise
even a good fighter can go down if
they're not prepared just like Korra
getting our ass handed to her at the
beginning of book 4 number 3 cores fight
with the giant spirit vine weapon tears
open a new spear portal so how about the
reveal of Korra stepping through the
spirit vines into the face of that giant
cannon that was probably my favorite
reaction shot from the episode just like
oh this was like kuvira Zula goes
crazy moment it wasn't quite the same
thing but yeah she definitely went to
look crazy like there are specific
points that you can point to along her
path where you could say okay she has
this really good plan she's acting very
rationally but her on the back of that
cannon like tiny kuvira on this giant
cannon is just the craziest thing in the
world and she has absolutely no
scientific understanding of how spirit
vine energy works it'd be like giving an
atomic bomb to just someone on the
street and saying okay you know go play
with this I don't think there was any
other way that it could have gone down
like something terrible had to happen
the spirit portal really was the biggest
surprise of the episode anything could
have happened you know lion turtle come
to jumped up the spirit vines could have
just
totally taken them all out had this been
like an HBO series I think there would
have been a lot more blood like the
spirit vines would have been ripping
people up but this is Nickelodeon it's a
children's show I did expect at some
point that Korra would take a full blast
from the gun like she would eat it and
either die or absorb it somehow so it
was glad that they took it to that level
like you can't get crazier than that
cords explanation was totally
satisfactory just the sheer spiritual
energy tore a hole between the physical
world and the spirit world creating a
new spirit portal and how beautiful was
the spirit world on the other side of
that portal the other side of the
southern portal is like this big
desolate area next to where that World
Tree is I like that they chose to make
this area look all flowery and nice like
a nice meadow very calming and serene
number two Julie and barracks wedding so
a couple of awesome things in this
episode between Julie and barrack we
learned their full names Julie moon and
sir ik Nick blackstone varrick and if
you didn't recognize it immediately they
were getting married on air temple
Island pretty much like all of downtown
was completely destroyed and overtaken
with the vibes in the spirit portal so
if you're looking at it they actually
they animated all the characters they
could into that scene if you ever saw
the simpsons movie it's just like that
like they did a big Church scene where
they had hundreds of characters in the
shot
normally what happens is when they do
big crowd shots is they only put faces
on the first couple of rows and then all
the background people that aren't in
focus they just do lesser versions of
just to save time and energy but in this
scene they completely animate everything
that's in frame it's not something you
think about right away but it becomes a
Herculean task to animate all these
faces especially when you have this
number of characters in frame also a
nice tahno shot turns out he's in a band
we also get to see Rohan I know every
one kids asking where is Rohan look at
how big he's gotten I actually confused
him with meelo when I first saw him a
lot of the characters also got really
cool costume changes but I think that
linen Korra's costumes were probably my
favorite of all the characters to get
different costumes the wedding dress
Julie's wedding dress was very nice too
a lot of this party scene is also
setting up what the action is going to
be for the characters after this episode
like in in the mythical fanfiction
territory or the comics so I'll address
that after I get done with my top 10
list and my number one moment the very
ambiguous maybe not so ambiguous
korrasami ending this is going to be the
most debated thing in the fandom for the
rest of time and I'm so happy they did
it this way not because I'm just like
hardcore korrasami
but just because of the reaction that it
causes in people it's just so fun to
watch it all play out I'm a big people
watcher like I really enjoy people going
crazy over stuff I mentioned it a little
bit earlier in the video but if you were
to go up to Mike and Brian at a
convention and say will you please you
know say definitively yes korrasami no
korrasami are they just really good
friends or is there something going on
here they probably would not answer you
not because they're trying to be mean
but just because they think that it's
more fun to leave it to the fans to
decide to be fair I think it is in the
subtext here but if you took it at the
literal interpretation no there's just
really good friends because it's a
children's show on Nickelodeon they
didn't get a lot of time to address
same-sex relationships that's really
left to subtext and children's
programming like you could argue that
spongebob is a gay character but there's
no way in hell they're ever gonna say
yes spongebob is gay no he's not gay
that's why I'm really proud that Mike
and Brian were so happy to go to that
place it is a big nod to the fandom it's
a little fanservice
but it's also a really smart way to say
hey you know baby there is something
going on here and yes I do think that
there are a lot of same-sex
relationships in the Corey universe in
the Avatar universe the best example I
can think of is Dumbledore JK Rowling
said after the fact the Dumbledore was a
gay character even though they never
directly addressed it inside the series
or inside the books just to be fair to
all parties to the Makah parties and the
korrasami parties mostly arguments I see
on tumblr or Twitter about whether or
not this is canon is just a measure of
how good you are as an arguer or a
debater
so just because someone is able to
convince someone else one way or the
other doesn't necessarily make it canon
I would actually be a little upset if
Mike and Brian came out and said
definitively one way or the other I just
I think it's too much fun to debate just
some more evidence - this is a nice
mirror for the ending where Aang kissed
Katara
let me know that what was your favorite
moment from the finale and what did you
think about the ending like which way do
you fall on the spectrum so just address
the next logical step for some of the
characters we pretty much explained he's
turning the earth kingdom into a
democracy they're going to be
independent states they'll operate just
like Republic City so he'll be more like
a
president will be much more democratic
ma KO is not going to go with him I was
actually really surprised by that
he'll just follow cor around as she
tries to help the earth Kingdom in the
rest of the world I know there are a lot
of complaints that he started out as a
really important character in book 1 and
slowly got less and less important but I
don't think it's so much about that I
think it's more about his own journey in
learning to be less selfish that's why
he's able to be with Korra without being
jealous although I do think yeah he
still loves Korra he's still totally in
love with her and just because they're
not together now doesn't mean they won't
end up together remember these
characters are still in their early 20s
think about the number of sexual
partners the average person has even if
korra and asami are going out now
doesn't mean that they're going to be
together for the rest of their lives 50%
of marriages end in divorce moving to
Bolin he's probably gonna be following
Marco around although I'm hoping that he
breaks every once in a while to make a
mover with varrick soohyun healing her
family they're probably gonna heal go
back and rebuild xiaofu kuvira going to
jail I'll be interested to see how many
times Cora visits her probably more
often than she visits here Tenzin just
going to continue chatting the air
nation interesting thing to note
harmonic convergence I think was
responsible for the creation of all the
new airbenders you could argue that
tearing open the new spear portal
increased the level of spiritual energy
in the physical world even more so there
could be even more benders now and they
did explain that Republic City is going
to expand which I actually think is
interesting which is the opposite of
what kuvira wanted it just Reiko didn't
want to rebuild around the spirit portal
that's why they're expanding overall I
give the episode of solid a-plus I mean
it was just amazing they did a good job
of wrapping everything up I know every
like little detail wasn't answered like
fans were pointing to that like Frank
did say we will tie up all the
storylines but people are like well what
happened to X character and Y character
a lot of that stuff like the little
things they'll leave for the comics
especially the original avatar
characters all of the big Korra
storylines were tied up and that's
really what we need to remember this was
a series about the Korra characters not
the original avatar characters so I do
forgive them for not stuffing every
original avatar character into every
available scene they did an amazing job
of leaving the characters in a place
that lets you know that there is a
future for everyone
the minute the episode ended all I could
see was everyone just posting please let
there be a Legend of Korra comic please
let there be a comic
yes I do think they will do it at some
point but they might not announce it for
a long time right now their priority is
the original avatar comic they do seem
happy to support that Nickelodeon I have
no idea what their plans are in terms of
digital content but they are done in
terms of doing full episodes they
haven't announced that our next project
but I will stay tuned I am going to
follow their career like I will do
whatever the next project is I'll do
videos for it but let's talk about the
animation you can just see how much
energy was going into all these scenes
everything which is absolutely beautiful
like each moment each scene each frame
which is this amazing background matte
painting
I feel like this totally makes up for
the clip show and really the clip show
had nothing to do with them that was all
Nickelodeon cutting their budget really
I can't say enough good things about
this series I'm just completely
satisfied with the way things ended so I
know everyone's wondering what's going
to be happening next so yes I am
planning on doing a live Q&A on my
twitch channel tomorrow I'll try to do
that around 12 p.m. Pacific time so
there's a link for that in the
description and yes I will be doing
Avatar videos for the original series
I'll try to post the first one in the
next couple of days but I'm going to do
a couple more Korra videos first please
leave requests for doing other anime
series thank you everyone for coming on
this chord journey with me it's been so
much fun doing videos for the series all
say is that no it is not over even
though there are new episodes doesn't
mean that we have to stop doing Korra
stuff on YouTube if you're watching this
on your mobile phone or on a tablet
there's new mobile links up here that
you can click on it's the same as the
links over here but but click here for
the Q&A I'll post that tomorrow I'm also
going to do the live Q&A on Twitch so
I'll post some of that to the YouTube
channel and then click here for all my
other avatar videos thank you so much
for watching let's all high five please
don't cry too much it's okay to cry a
little bit
you